Speaker 1: All right, let's continue our coverage.
Who who knew that a simple Senate hearing about
COVID would lead to this much to discuss and so
many important issues that have to be taken apart
piece by piece by piece? We recently told you
about when Ted Cruz had to go in front of his
master. I mean, Fox News propagandist Tucker
Carlson and grovel and say, I'm sorry, Tucker.
I was stupid. I said something wrong. I shouldn't
have called the Jan. six rioters terrorists.
I'm sorry, I misspoke. And he had to do a mea
culpa in front of the person who really has the
power in that relationship, not the U.S. senator,
but the Fox News propagandist Tucker Carlson. Now,
Tucker Carlson loves, loves, loves the
conspiracy theory that a man named Ray
Epps was supposedly a Trumpist, but actually an
undercover fed inciting the riots because the FBI
organized the Trump riots as a false flag
attack. That's sort of the gist of it. And you
might remember that during their interview,
right after Ted Cruz was done groveling,
Tucker started talking about Ray Epps and Ted Cruz
seeing it as an opportunity to get back on the
good great in the good graces of Tucker went right
along with it. OK? This is from the other day,
Speaker 2: and I agree that snippet. So who's
raps? By the way, since you are a senator like
he and this other guy are clearly encouraging
your crowd to commit crimes? Neither one has been
arrested or charged. What is that, do you think?
So I think that is a very good question. I
don't know who Ray Epps is. I've seen that video
multiple times. It's right, Irving. He's clearly
urging the crowd to violate the law. When you see
the crowd start chanting Fed, Fed, Fed for him to
appear on the FBI's most wanted list and come off,
it certainly suggests he was working for the FBI.
Speaker 1: Now that is, that is riddled with
lies. Let me let me play a little more than
I'll get back to inconclusive, conclusive.
Speaker 2: But that's the obvious implication.
And the attorney general and the Department
of Justice won't answer the question. Tucker,
I can tell you, I joined with a number of other
senators trying to. OK, so you get the point.
Speaker 1: Tucker loves this conspiracy theory
now. It is just a conspiracy theory. No one.
Ray Epps was never on the FBI's most wanted.
He was. He was never on the FBI's most wanted.
There's a list that's the FBI's most wanted. And
then there's other things like when the FBI will
release a picture of people that they want to talk
to and after the Trump riots. Ray Epps and I have
the picture up on the screen was on one of these
pictures in chronological order from people they
saw in the lower left. There's a picture of Ray
Epps there. This is not the FBI's most wanted,
and not every person on this list was charged.
It wasn't only Ray Epps. What do we know about
Ray Epps? Ray Epps owns a wedding and event
venue in Arizona. He's a retired U.S. marine.
He's a Trump supporter. He's connected to
the anti-government group the Oath Keepers,
and he was listed as president of the
Arizona chapter. Ray Epps is on videos
in advance of the riots the day before, saying
We've got to go to the Capitol and some people
in the crowd go no fed. And ultimately, it's
it's what they did on the day of the riots.
He was there, but he did not participate in
the violence. And in fact, there are videos
of Ray Epps saying, Let's not get violent. So
everything Ted Cruz is saying or tucker it,
some of it, it's just straight up lies. And
some of it really doesn't mean much one way
or the other. Like, let me give you an example,
Usher rung up a tweeted the fact that there was
one guy out of a thousand people who were on an
FBI person of interest list and then was taken off
is not evidence that January 6th was an FBI led
operation. Additionally, confidential informants
and sources are not. Feds are not feds. So even if
Ray Epps was a confidential informant for the FBI,
that doesn't make him any more a fed than when
a drug dealer is a confidential informant to
the DEA about higher ups. That's not a DEA
agent. There's not a Fed, it's a drug dealer
who's agreed to cooperate with the FBI with the
DEA, but none of that's even been demonstrated.
But Ted Cruz had to go and do Tucker's bidding.
Ted Cruz went and brought the Ray Eppes thing
to the Senate hearing.
Speaker 2: Take a look at this.
I want to turn to the FBI. How many FBI agents
Speaker 1: or and I'm sorry, I think earlier
I said this was a hearing on COVID. This is
a hearing on January 6th. I think I missed,
but now I'm I think I just misspoke.
Speaker 2: Earlier and shrill informants
actively participated in
the events of January 6th.
Sir, I'm sure you can appreciate that I can't
go into the specifics of sources and methods.
Did any FBI agents or confidential informants
actively participate in the events of January six
Speaker 1: now understand the
way he's asking the question?
These are completely different questions. Did FBI
agents participate in the riots? Did confidential
informants participate in the riots? These are
completely different questions, neither of which
has anything to do with raps individually.
Speaker 2: Yes or no,
sir. I can't. I can't answer that.
Speaker 1: And Ted Cruz knows that.
That can't be answered in this format,
and it is such a vague and broad question.
Speaker 2: Did any FBI agents are confidential?
Informants commit crimes of violence on January
six? I can't answer that, sir. Did any FBI agents
or FBI informants actively encourage and incite
crimes of violence on January six? Sir, I can't
answer that. Mr Abbott, who is Rapp's depth?
I'm aware of the individual, sir. I don't
have the specific background to him. Well,
there are a lot of people who are understandably
concerned about Mr Abbott, about Mr Abbott. On
the night of January 5th, 2021, EPS
wandered around the crowd that had gathered
and there's video out there
have been chanting Tomorrow
we need to get into the capital, into the capital.
This was strange behavior so strange that the
crowd began chanting, He's got fed fed.
Speaker 1: He's got charts on the floor
of this hearing room. Pictures of reps
Speaker 2: at Fed Fed Mason Byrne was Ray the
Fed. Sir, I cannot answer that question
Speaker 1: the next and of course,
the conspiracists say, well, if it can't be
answered no, then the answer must be yes. But
anybody who understands such a hearing would know
under no circumstances would someone from the FBI
or DOJ answer questions in the way
that Ted Cruz wants them answered
is not evidence of anything today.
Speaker 2: That said on January six.
Mr Abbott is seen whispering to a person and
five seconds later, five seconds after he's
whispering to a person, that same person begins to
forcibly tear down the barricades. Did Mr. Eppes
urge them to tear down the barricades? Sir, so
much of the other answers, I cannot answer that,
Speaker 1: so they are absolutely loving this.
This was a narrative pushed by right wing media
to Ted Cruz. Loves it. Ted Cruz is using it to get
back in the good graces of the American right wing
after he had to go and grovel before Tucker
Carlson. Epps himself says he has never been
an informant for the FBI. He has never been an
informant for any law enforcement agency, and he
is obviously not an FBI agent. He's a right wing
anti-government group, dude. And this is this they
are absolutely running with this one, and I will
show you how quickly they can signal boost this.